ونحييكم الى نقاش الملف الاول وسط تعثر
المفاوضات الهادفه الى اجراء الاتفاق
واحياء الاتفاق النووي مع الغرب يعود ملف
نشاطات ايران النوويه الى الواجهه بعدها
حديث اسرائيلي عن توسيع طهران لمنشاهنا
النوويه في عمق كبير تحت الارض وسط البلاد
رئيس منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه محمد
اسلامي نفهما اسماه مزاعم اسرائيليه واتهم
اسلامي اسرائيل باللجوء الى بعض الادعاءات
في كل مره تتعرض فيها تل ابيب لاوقات صعبه
كما قال في المنطقه او في محيطها مشيرا
الى ان تلك الاتهامات تدخل في اطار
العمليات النفسيه واضاف رئيس منظمه الطاقه
الذريه الايرانيه ان ايران تعمل وفقا
لمعايير الوكاله الدوليه وللضمانات وان
نشاطاتها تتم بالتنسيق مع الوكاله كما ان
بلاده ستتعاون مع المفتشين الدوليين بشان
اي انشطه جديده تصريحات
هذه تاثير ردا على تهديد مستشار الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي بان المنشاه النوويه
الايرانيه الجديده ليست بمنئه عن اي هجوم
مضيفا انه لا يوجد مكان لا يمكن الوصول
اليه لكنه لفتاه الى ان الحلول امام هذا
التحدي كما اسماه لا تزال متوفره هذه
الاتهامات المتبادله جاءت بعد تقرير
لوكاله استشهيده بريس عرض هذا التقرير
صورا تكشف قيم ايران بحفر انفاق تحت الارض
بالقرب من مفاعل طنز النووي
نشرت وكاله اسوشيت بريس صورا التقطتها
اقمار صناعيه قالت ان طهران تبني منشاه
نوويه جديده بالقرب من مفاعل طنز النووي
الذي تعرض الانفجار وحريق في يوليو من عام
2020 وحسب تفسير مؤسسه بلانيت لابس بي بي
سي التي التقطت الصور فان المنشاه الجديده
تقع بالقرب من قمه جبال زاجروس وسط ايران
وعلى بعد 225 كيلو مترا جنوب طهران وان
المنشاه الجديده تشيد على عمق كبير حيث
يقوم العمال بحفر انفاق واربعه مداخل على
سفح جبل يقع خلف السياج الجنوبي لمنشات
واوضحت بلانيت لابس ان موقع المنشات
الجديده يجعلها خارج نطاق الاسلحه
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
تقدمت ايران في برنامجها النووي في
السنوات الاخيره في تخسيب اليورانيوم اكثر
من اي وقت مضى نحن نراقب عن كثب ايضا
المجالات المتعلقه بالتطوير النووي وبدون
الخوض في التفاصيل ايضا بسبب الوقت ساقول
ان هناك تطورات سلبيه محتمله في الافق
ويمكن ان تؤدي الى اتخاذ اجراءات وهذا امر
مهم للغايه
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من
فلوريدو تحالف الامريكي شرق قوستي من اجل
الديمقراطيه اهلا بك من طهران محمد صالح
صادقيان المحلل السياسي اهلا بكم ضيوفي
الكرام واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من فرض معك
سيطم سيتام كيف تقرا هذه التصريحات
الاسرائيليه بمعنى هل تعتقد بان ايران
تسعى فعلا لتوسيع نطاق منشات النوويه
وزياده عمليات تخصيبها لليورانيوم ام ان
كل هذا مزاعم اسرائيليه وان ايران حتى ان
فكرت في انشاء مؤسسه او منشاه جديده
فسيكون هذا بالتعاون مع وكاله الطاقه
الذريه
مرحبا لكي الكريم وللمشاهدين هلا ليس فقط
الاسرائيليين الذين تكلموا عن هذا الموضوع
وان وانما المتحدث باسم الوكاله الدوليه
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه كذلك تكلم عن تقسيط
كميه التي تعدت هي بالفعل مستوى
الاعمال للطاقه الكهربائيه وهنالك مخابرات
امريكيه ومخابرات اوروبيه تكلمت عن هذا في
السنوات الماضيه ولكن هذه المره بالذات
حسب تقرير التي قدمتموه بانه
التنقيب تحت الارض بنفق غميق غامق اوبن 80
و100 متر لمنع اي ضربه عسكريه ان كانت
اسرائيليه اما امريكيه للوصول الى الجهاز
النووي تحت الارض ولكن هذه المعلومات هي
كانت متوفره بالسابق تكلموا عنها
الاسرائيليين
يتكلم عنها عده مخابرات دوليه هلا ماذا
العمل هذا هو السؤال وهو بالفعل يعني
هنالك شك منه
استراتيجي سياسي يعني ان كانت اسرائيل اما
دول الجوار الدول العربيه يخشون النووي
الايراني والجزء الثاني هو اقتصادي وهنا
مصالح الشركات الكبرى ان كانت الشركات
الامريكيه والاوروبيه الذين يحسون هذه
الدول الغربيه بالتعامل مع ايران لاجل
لاجل المكاسب الاقتصاديه بغض النظر عن
الوضع الامني وتهديد ايران لدول الجوار من
قبل النووي سيتم ابقى معك حتى يجهز ضيفي
من طهران الاستاذ الصادقين فقدناه لبعض
لحظات هل تعتقد بانه الظروف الاقتصاديه
التي تعيشها ايران لن تثنيها على انشاء
مثل هكذا
مباني جديده وقد وكذلك تضعها امام مخاوف
الغرب هل هناك
يمكن ان نتحدث عنها بخصوص كل ما تقوم به
في هذه المرحله
يعني اذا رجعنا لل 2012 13 14 بعهد الرئيس
اوباما كان الاقتصاد الايراني بحوال 600
مليار دولار سنويا وانما في عهد الرئيس
ترامب بعد العقوبات التي وضعها انخفض الى
250 مليار دولار ولكن بعد الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه
والتحالفات الجديده التي تمت بعث الصين
ودول عديده في المنطقه والروسيه وايران
وهؤلاء وبعد اتفاقيه اقتصاديه عسكريه بين
الصين وايران مما دفع بالاقتصاد
الايراني
للتصاعد من جديد وهم باستطاعتهم ان يقوموا
ما يقومون به من الناحيه الاقتصاديه هذا
معكبه الشعب الايراني الذي هو يدفع ثمن
السياسه الايرانيه
استاذ صادقين منشاه جديده
نشرت صورا بخصوصها السوشال بريس واكدتها
تصريحات اسرائيليه وامريكيه كذلك مفادها
بان ايران تسعى لانشاء منشاه جديده
بهدف تخصيب اليورانيوم او حتى بهدف
متابعه تطوير
الاسطوانات المركزيه او طرد المركزي هذا
التوقيت ما دلالات ان يتم نشر مثل هكذا
تقارير في هذا التوقيت بالتحديد
من اقرب للصوره واقرب للارض للتفتيش
ولمتابعه كل هذه التفاصيل هذا صحيح جدا
المخاوف هذه المخاوف ليست مخاوف النيه
وانما مخاوف سياسيه المشكله مشكله
البرنامج النووي الايراني وبمشكله الملف
النووي الايراني هي عندما خرج الرئيس
ترامب من او انسحب من الاتفاق النووي كلنا
يعلم الاتفاق النووي كان ينص على ان ايران
يحق لها او لا يحق لها تخصيب اليورانيوم
اكثر من ثلاثه بوينت سته سبعه وبالتالي
ايران ايضا من الفتره 2005 2015 الى
الفتره 2018 عندما انسحبت الولايات
المتحده من الاتفاق النووي كانت تخصب بهذه
النسبه نسبه
3.67 المشكله ظهرت عندما انسحب الرئيس
ترامب وفرض عقوبات وهذه العقوبات كان لديه
يعني
لديها انعكاسات كبيره لدى الجانب الايراني
ماذا تعمل ايران عندما فرضت عليها مثل هذه
العقوبات القاسيه وبحيث هو الرئيس ترامب
قال قال لا يوجد لدينا شيء اخر نفرض
بعقوبات نفرض عليه عقوباته هذه هي المشكله
لم افهم هذه النقطه سيد صادقين قبل
الانتقال فلوريدا لضيفي لم افهم هذه
النقطه تقول بانه مع فرض العقوبات لم تجد
ايران الا هذا خيار ولكن منشات وتخصيب
وطرد مركزي فيما ينفعها اقتصاديا فيما
ينفعها مقابل هذه العقوبات
القضيه التي تخص ماذا ينفعها وما
يضرها هذه تتبع سياسه الحكومه الايرانيه
والبرلمان الايراني ومراكز القرار في داخل
اليونان هم يعرفون ماذا يخدم بلدهم او لا
لكن المشكله التي نحن الان بصددها هل ان
ايران تعمل خارج خارج قانون الضمانات
التابع الطاقه الذريه هذا هو المهم هل ان
هذه المنشاه الجديده هي فعلا موجوده
الايرانيين يقولون هذه اكاذيب تسوقها
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وبالتالي هم يريدون
اثاره الراي العام هناك اهداف اخرى وراء
هذا العمل لكن هل ان المنشات النوويه
الايرانيه خارج اطار اعين المفتشين
التابعين للوكاله الدوليه المعلومات التي
انا امتلكها والمعلومات التي يقولها
المسؤولون الايرانيين يقولون بان كل
مفاصيل البرنامج النووي الايراني
والمشاهدات النوويه الايرانيه هي تحت اعين
ومراقبه الوكاله
وفي اطار كذلك ضمانات وهذا ما اكده رئيس
منظمه طاقه اداريه الايرانيه محمد اسلامي
سيتم ضيف يقول بان ترامبو الذي يتحمل
مسؤوليه مقاله اليه الامور حتى وان كانت
هناك ما وصفه البعض بتجاوزات ايرانيه بعد
خروج الولايات المتحده الامريكيه فتره
يتحملوا المسؤوليه
نقطتين هنا النقطه الاولى هي بانه الاتفاق
النووي بعهد الرئيس اوباما كان لديه غروب
شمس بعد 15 سنه وغروب الشمس
2015-2030 عندئذ تقوم ايران بما لديها
بدون اي معاقبه اما اي مراقبه دوليه ثاني
نقطه كمان بالنسبه
للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه عليها ان
تبلغ ايران 30 نهار قبل المجيء الى ايران
للكشف واي مكان سيكشفون واي منطقه وتحدد
المناطق للكشف والمراقبه من قبل الوكاله
الدوليه فلذلك الامر يعني هو كان يعني
اثنيناتهم الدول الغربيه اللي فاتوا
بالاتفاق مع ايران اثنيناتهم كانوا
منسجمين بذلك القرار للقضيه الاقتصاديه
الذي يهم الشركات الغربيه ضمن ايران ولكن
كان في ايران في الاتفاق النووي كان موجود
2015 شيء معلن وهنالك كان ملفين اما
نقطتين مهمين غير معلنين للراي العام ولكن
تسبد الوقائع انه ايران هي تقوم بعمليه
تخصيب الاورانيوم لقنبله ذريه وليس لمصلحه
العمل السلمي كما يقول تتحدث في عهد ترامب
على سؤالي هو ضيفي يقول المشكله ليست في
تطوير ايران ليست في انشائها منشات كل
التصريحات الايرانيه تتفق على انه هذه
المنشات او اي تحرك ايراني هو يحترم
ضمانات الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
ولكن ان كانت هناك تجاوزات يتحملها ترامب
تتحملها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بخروجها من اتفاق كان على الاقل يراعي
الحد الادنى هذا ما يقوله الاستاذ صديقين
طبعا الاستاذ صديقي ان يتكلم انه شو
الموقف الايراني ولكن الموقف الدولي بما
فيه الدول العربيه وحتى اداره الرئيس
ترامب كانت تخشى من انه الاتفاق الذي
انعمل هو لمرحله قصيره فقط لمرحله 15 سنه
ويجب العوده الى اتفاق ليس لديه غروب شمس
وهذا الاتفاق اذا لديه غروب شمس ويجب على
الوكاله الدوليه ان تقوم
بزيارات مفاجئه الى ايران ربما سيكون
اتفاق افضل فانسحب من الاتفاق ليكون هنالك
اتفاق افضل فاستغله النظامي ليقول هذا ليس
هو بالفعل نحن تراجعنا على الاتفاق الذي
قمنا به بعهد الرئيس اوباما سيد صديقان لا
يخفى على حضرتك بان مخاوف الغرب في كل مره
تكبر وتتوسع مع هذه التصريحات او هذه
التقارير التي تؤكد
ان طهران تسعى
لمتابعه تخصيبها لليورانيوم واسرائيل كانت
هددت وقالت بانه حتى وان كانت ايران تحاول
انشاء هذه المنشاه الجديده في منطقه يصعب
الوصول لها ولكن لدينا دائما حلول هل هناك
مخاوف حقيقيه من ان يتحول الصراع الى
استهدفات مباشره تطال المنشات الايرانيه
من الجانب الاسرائيلي
بدايه اقول بان
الجانب الامريكي والاسرائيلي عندما
يتحدثون عن هذه المنشاه الجديده التي حفرت
داخل الارض كنفق هم لا يتحدثون بان هذه
تتعارض مع ضمانات الوكاله الدوليه ومن
يتحدثون باننا لا يمكن ان نصل اليها وهذا
فرق كبير بين الحالتين النقطه الثانيه
انا يعني انسجم مع ما تفضلت به هو وجود
قلق عند الجانبين عند الجانب الامريكي
والاوروبي والغربي بشكل عام والجانب
الايراني هناك حاجز عدم الثقه موجود بين
الجانبين الاتفاق النووي الذي تم التوقيع
عليه في عهد الرئيس اوباما في العام 2015
هو اراد ان يعزز الثقه بين الجانبين ان
تكون هناك ثقه لدى الايرانيين من اعمال
وسلوك وتصرفات الجانب الامريكي وان يكون
هناك ثقه من الجانب الغربي
لسلوك الايراني بشكل عام لكن هذا الانسحاب
الذي وصفه الرئيس بعيدا بانه انسحاب خطا
وتصرف وسلوك خطا عندما انسحبت الولايات
المتحده من الوكاله الدوليه هذا هذه هذه
كارثه كانت لايران ولا الغرب ولا الولايات
المتحده وانا اعتقد بعد الانسحاب الامريكي
من الاتفاق النووي من حق الولايات المتحده
انت تقلق من البرنامج
انا معك فيما يخص ازمه ثقه بين الطرفين
ولكن قد يقول لك
مراقبون بانه ازمه ثقه هذه اسست لها كذلك
تصريحات سياسيه ايرانيه هناك من تلاعب
بموضوع الملف النووي او لعب عليه وبه
لمحاوله الضغط في ملفات اخرى وحضرتك تعلم
بهذا الموضوع ايران لما تنشئ منشاه جديده
الى اي مدى هذا الموضوع
قد يمثل اداه لتتحرش من خلال باسرائيل
وهذا قد يضعنا في اطار تصعيد خطير
هذه المنشاه اليوم هو نفى مدير الوكاله
الدوليه
المدير
الوكاله الايرانيه الذريه نفى هذه
المعلومات وقال بان هذه المعلومات غير
صحيحه وغير دقيقه وقال ايضا بان كل
البرنامج انه الايراني وما تقوم به ايران
في برنامج النووي يخضع للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه هذه نقطه سطر ويبدو لي لحد
الان الوكاله الدوليه لم تتحدث لا عن هذه
المنشاه الجديده ولا عن غيرها ولم تقل بان
ايران عارضت الوكاله او لم تخبر الوكاله
لا يوجد تصريح من قبل الوكاله بهذا الشان
وهي الوكاله المتخصصه دوليا في مراقبه
الانشطه النوويه للدول الاعضاء وايران ع
النقطه المهم هل انها مثل هذا
اي تحرك او سلوك نووي ايراني يمكن ان
يستفز اسرائيل ان يعتقد بان اسرائيل لا
تريد اقل من تفكيك البرنامج النووي
الايراني حتى وان كان مستوى التخصيب واحد
بالمئه لان اسرائيل والامن القومي
الاسرائيلي يعتمد على قاعده التفوق
الاسرائيلي العلمي والاكاديمي والتقني لكل
دول المنطقه وبالتالي نحن راينا في
اتفاقيات كانديفيد بقضيه التفوق
الاسرائيلي كان مهم في هذه الاتفاقيات
وحتى في اتفاقيات وادي عربه الان اسرائيل
تنظر للبرنامج النووي الايراني بانه يهدد
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي وبالتالي هي وقفت
وراء الرئيس ترامب من اجل انسحاب من
الاتفاق النووي والرئيس ترامب عندما وقع
على الانسحاب هو قال كلمه
اظن بانكم تذكرون قال وفيت بعهدي وعندما
قال وفيت بعهدي كان يعني بانه وفا بعهده
اللوبي اليهودي الموجود في داخل الولايات
المتحده ايباك والحكومه الاسرائيليه باني
اريد خرجت من هذا الاتفاق وكانوا يريدون
انهيار الاتفاق النووي ايرانهم تصرفت بما
تراه مناسبا من اجل الحفاظ على امنها
القومي وسيادتها على كل الانشطه وهي تؤكد
عضويتها الطبيعيه في الوكاله الدوليه
لطاقه هل تعتقد بان اسرائيل من خلال هذه
التقارير هي التي تريد تصعيد الموضوع حتى
يتحرك الغرب تجاه ايران كما يقول ضيفي
ولتفكيك مشروحه النووي او العكس او ان
ايران هي التي تعمل بغنى عما يمكن ان يفكر
فيه البقيه
يعني اسرائيل اذا تتخوف من ايران النووي
مش بالبرنامج السلمي لانه بدولارات من
اربع خمس سنين لليوم ب14 منشات نوويه
لبرامج سلميه واسرائيل منهم وانما المنشات
الايرانيه هي لسلاح نووي وليس تخوف
لاسرائيل فقط وانما الدول العربيه ودول
الجوار وثانيا نقطه اذا بالفعل هذا برنامج
سلمى يعني تصرف ايران بالمنطقه يجب يكون
سلميا وليس لا يكون لها ازرعه من حماس
بغزه لحزب الله في لبنان الحشد الشعبي في
ايران الحوسيين في اليمن كل اولي خلقوا
مشاكل للدول العربيه ما مصلحه ايران في ان
تنشئ منشاه جديده وان تنشر هكذا تقارير
حتى وان كانت تقارير تفضحها ان كانت لا
تنشئ هذه المنشات باحترام ضمانات وكاله
دوليه للطاقه الذريه ما مصلحتها في وقت هي
تسعى اولا لاعاده علاقاتها مع محيطها ومع
المجتمع الدولي هي تسعى ثانيا للعوده
للاتفاق النووي بطريقه او باخرى ما
مصلحتها بان تقف وبان تطرح مثل هكذا نقطه
قد تكون مزعجه ومستفزه للبقيه
[موسيقى]
فعلا تعاقد الموضوع مع الجانب الاسرائيلي
خاصه هل ايران يمكن ان تواجه مثل هكذا
تصعيد ليس فقط اسرائيلي ولكن حضرتك اشرت
منذ قليل الى من يدعم اسرائيل في الجانب
الامريكي
هذا صحيح جدا وايران مستعده لمواجهه مثل
هكذا تهديدات وبالتالي انا اعتقد بان
ايران عندما تكون عضو في الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه يجب عليها الوكاله الدوليه
تتحمل جزء من المسؤوليه للحفاظ على
البرامج البرنامج النووي الايراني مثل ما
هي مسؤوليتها في الحفاظ على كل البرامج
النوويه لكل الدول الاعضاء في الوكاله
الدوليه هذه نقطه النقطه الثانيه انا
اعتقد وكتبت في ذلك بان اسرائيل لا يمكن
لها الاعتداء على ايران او اعتداء اخر
سواء كان لبنان غزه
بمصر في 73 في الاردن اي اعتداء لماذا
في اي اعتداء اعتدت به على او دخلت في حرب
هي اخذت الضوء الى اخضر من الجانب
الامريكي وعملت جسرا جويا من اجل الاعتداء
وبالتالي الان لا يمكن لها ان تعتدي على
ايران الا ان تاخذ الضوء الاخضر ولا اعتقد
يعني هذه المؤشرات الامريكيه تقول الان
الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه اداره ترامب
ليست في وارد ان تعطي مثل هذا الضوء
الاخضر لانها مشغله في الكثير من الملفات
وبالتالي الحرب على ايران ليست نزهه
وعندما تكون مثل هذه الحرب بهذا الحجم
ربما تكون الطلقه الاولى اسرائيليه لكن
بالتاكيد الطلقه الاخيره سوف لن تكون
الاسرائيليه والمسؤولون الايرانيين خصوصا
في القوات المسلحه الايرانيه ليتوعدون
الجانب الاسرائيلي بضربه حاسمه ورد قاطع
واني اعتقد بان اسرائيل او الولايات
المتحده اذا ارادت التفكير بمواجهه
بمعاجمه ايران
بالتاكيد سوف تفكر اكثر من مره قبل ان
تقوم بمثل هذا الاعتناء ولكن حضرتك ترى
بانها لن تقوم بذلك ولن تعطي حتى ضوء
الاخضر لاسرائيل طيب سنكتفي بهذا القدر
على ان نتابع الموضوع في حلقه اخرى اود
شكركم الجزيل الشكر من طهران محمد صالح
صادقيان المحلل السياسي شكرا لك ومن
فلوريدا حرب مدير تحالف الامريكيه شرق
قوسطي من اجل الديمقراطيه شكرا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات